Welcome back everyone this is my suicide squad
alternate ending deleted scenes video and
alternate storyline with superman that's right
james gunn revealed a whole bunch of secrets
about what was going on with the original version
of the movie so we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos there's a bunch of really big
stuff coming up this week careful for spoilers
if you have not seen the suicide squad movie
because we'll be talking about everything that
happened during that but recently james gunn has
been revealing a lot of alternate endings deleted
scenes alternate storylines for the suicide squad
movie and even some fully alternate dc movies that
werner brothers tried to get him to make when he
first started working on the suicide squad movie
some of those other early ideas that he wound up
not doing will eventually turn into future dc
movies and james gunn did say that he would
be doing more dc movies with dc villains probably
after guardians of the galaxy 3 is done just got a
tiny little marvel movie to make and then release
that peacemaker hbo series that they just teased
during the post-credits scene but probably the
biggest bombshell that he dropped this past week
is that he revealed an alternate suicide squad
storyline that he started with that was going to
be all about superman instead of starro all those
of you hoping for a new henry cavill superman
movie these past couple of years he did say back
in 2018 when he was first meeting with them that
warner brothers tried to get him to make a regular
superman movie like that was the first thing that
they said when they were offering him different
ideas like here these are all the movies that
you could do he did say that warner brothers gave
him his pick of anything he could do anything he
wanted with the exception of maybe like batman
because i think at that time they were still
trying to figure out the ben affleck batman movie
in the matt reeves batman movie but literally he
could have made any movie that he wanted so it
sounds like back in the middle of 2018 when he was
first meeting with them and they landed on suicide
squad his initial idea to make superman the main
villain of the movie like suicide squad versus
superman instead of starro that idea came out of
warner brothers desire for a new superman project
of some kind because it sounds like when this was
happening a couple of years ago they really really
wanted the right person to swoop in and make a
new superman movie so the suicide squad versus
superman movie was basically the first version
of this movie that we just got done watching
obviously the plot would have been very different
because of the way they explained starro's
backstory and cortal maltese but this is me just
quoting the way that he talked about it so i'm
paraphrasing him he said when i started writing
the suicide squad one idea was that they would
fight superman the suicide squad has to catch
superman for some reason superman has gotten out
of hand or superman is being controlled by someone
like mind controlled and then this group of super
lousy villains has to face the most powerful hero
in the world you also have to remember that
when this was happening james gunn had also just
finished making the breitburn movie so you can
see how he had evil superman on the brain because
that movie is kind of an evil superman movie or a
homelander movie if you want to make a reference
to the boys and of course his suicide squad vs
evil superman movie sounds a lot like the plot
of the justice league snyder cut in zack snyder's
versions of justice league 2 and justice league 3.
after the snyder cut came out earlier this year
zack snyder released storyboards and details on
what was going to happen in those justice league
sequels i've already done really really long super
detailed breakdown videos for all that so we'll
add links for it in the description if you want to
watch those videos and get the full story of the
sequels but basically what we get in the nightmare
scene is the post-apocalyptic version of batman
trying to hold together a sort of combination of
what's left of the justice league they partnered
with the joker deathstrokes some other dc villains
in order to stop evil superman who's being
mind controlled by darkseid using the anti-life
equation now when james gunn was talking about his
evil superman storyline in the suicide squad movie
none of that would have spilled into multiple
sequels the way that zack snyder was planning out
his trilogy storyline it wouldn't have involved
time travel like zack snyder's justice league
sequels and even though he would have had to
reference the justice league in some way because
you have superman you have to reference the
justice league when he shows up in that version
of his suicide squad movie batman wonder woman the
flash aquaman green lantern even martian manhunter
probably would not have been huge characters
because the whole idea of the movie the whole
pitch was that it was supposed to be a bunch of
rejects versus the most powerful being on the
planet like how the hell are they ever going
to be superman is almost impossible let alone
evil superman like regular superman would try
to avoid killing anyone so you might be able to
reason with him but evil superman who does not
pull his punches is like the angel of death you
have zero chance of survival unless you're laced
with kryptonite or you have batman on your team
so in that early version of the suicide squad
james gunn probably wasn't going to be using the
anti-life equation or dark side to be the source
of superman's mind control there is an upcoming
suicide squad kills the justice league video game
that rocksteady is making they released a trailer
for that at dc fandom last year and in that
story their whole explanation for why superman
breaks bad and turns evil is that brainiac is
the real main villain he invades earth and one
of his first acts is to mind control superman so
really that story is more like the suicide squad
kills brainiac and then avoids having to deal with
superman directly because in james gunn's suicide
squad versus evil superman movie there was no way
that they were going to be able to kill superman
like warner brothers would never have allowed them
to kill superman again and since it would have
only been one movie with evil superman knowing
his comedic style of writing these storylines
it sounds like whoever james gunn would have had
being the person controlling superman it would
have been someone from earth like lex luthor or
because james gunn loves doing really weird really
obscure characters like polka dot man is a really
good example of that the person mind controlling
superman probably would have been a super obscure
dc villain with mind control powers the version
of the movie that we actually got in theaters and
on hbo max also sounds like it was born from some
of the elements of that original evil superman
version of the movie so because of the way he
used the us government as the secret main villain
of the actual film it also sounds like maybe the
government would have secretly been behind the
attempts to mind control superman and in the
way that they were using the thinker villain to
experiment on starro weaponizing his mind control
they would have hired another dc villain or maybe
thinker as well to try and mind control superman
using some other technology or even using another
version of starro and that's how evil superman
spirals out of control things go off the rails
and then that's when amanda waller has to call
on the suicide squad to clean up the government's
mess again to try and save face because at the end
of that version of the movie they stop superman
from being mind controlled they don't kill him
off and superman doesn't wind up feeling like an
actual villain during the film like you meant to
feel sorry for superman the way you feel sorry
for starro even though starro winds up killing a
whole bunch of people it sounds like one of the
reasons why the studio told him no to the evil
superman mind control storyline is because back in
2018 they were just coming off that justice league
movie fiasco and they'd already had a pretty dark
superman storyline play out during that and warner
brothers sounded like they just did not want
another dark superman story the shazam movie was
coming out they used superman during that ending
scene and it seems a lot brighter more hopeful
things in the world seem like they're back to
normal after the events of the justice league film
in warner brothers just sounds like they didn't
want to do another homelander style superman movie
so james gunn just kept the mind control
subplot and made it all about starro then
moving things to quartal maltese in that nazi base
Jotunheimen and adding all those plot elements
i don't think the studio saying no had anything to
do with the justice league snyder cut because yes
it's the exact same storyline basically a bunch of
heroes and villains have to stop evil superman to
save the world but make it time travel and way
more cosmic with darkseid but warner brothers
didn't start meeting with zack snyder to actually
green light the snyder cut to later in 2019 almost
a year after james gunn had started working with
warner brothers on the suicide squad movie so when
james gunn was pitching his evil superman in 2018
at that time the studio had no intention of doing
the snyder cut that didn't come till much later
and even when it comes to the snyder cut with the
evil superman scenes and teasers for the sequels
with darkseid zack snyder actually said that the
studio had no idea that he was going to do that
stuff in the movie in fact the studio specifically
asked him not to shoot any new footage and he
said basically screw you i'm going to do whatever
i want and filmed all the nightmare scenes in his
driveway like he put green screens up in his own
driveway at his personal house and filmed all that
stuff himself he also added all those scenes of
cyborg getting the visions from the mother box of
the possible future timeline with superman going
evil with darkseid and killing the rest of the
justice league members if he'd actually pitched
that to the studio when they were hashing out what
the snyder cut was going to be warner brothers
probably would have tried to stop the cut from
actually coming out now if you do like the idea
of the suicide squad versus the justice league
or suicide squad versus superman james gunn did
say that when the studio said no to his suicide
squad versus justice league character's idea that
they might wind up doing that as a future sequel
movie and if they did he asked them specifically
please let me be involved with this like if you
ever do it please let me come back and do this
so it sounds like warner brothers might still
do a version of that in a movie at some point
the other big alternate ending scenes for the
suicide squad movie that he recently explained
were originally the movie would have had a much
darker ending like the actual ending of the movie
seems relatively light and happy despite all the
moments the body count is very high but the vibe
overall is positive the way they leave things with
all the characters they defeat starro even though
it's a tragic death bloodsport befriends sebastian
the rat amanda waller calls it truce because of
the hard drive data they all get to go free the
survivors get to go free even peacemaker seems
like his life is looking up in the original ending
it sounds like amanda waller would have actually
pressed more buttons killing a couple other
team members i believe they were also going to
play harley quinn's ending as if she really does
almost die like they take her way closer to death
they still would have defeated starro but the
music tracks that they play over all this probably
would have been way more like they play it more
for comedy like you have polka dot man taking down
his mother and it's kind of a funny moment also
the way they play harley quinn killing starr with
the javelin like jumping into his eye it plays
out almost exactly like the dream sequence from
earlier in the movie when she's hallucinating
all the flowers killing those guards while
she's escaping from prison so it sounds like james
gunn's original darker ending just made the studio
worry that it would feel too much like the darker
ending from the original suicide squad movie
the only character james gunn said that he
never planned on killing off at any point was
king shark just he loved that character so much he
never wanted to kill him otherwise it does sound
like there were other versions of these ending
scenes where the main characters outside of king
shark either die or wind up more like peacemaker
like completely mangled bodies in a coma or in a
hospital bed at some point but the next big sequel
that james gunn is working on in the dc universe
is that john cena peacemaker hbo series it's a
direct sequel to the events of the movie he's
going to be going out on more missions for amanda
waller there'll be eight episodes total and it's
going to start airing in january i will be doing
full episode videos for that they did say that
it will set up and cross over with other future dc
movies they didn't say which future dc movies it's
going to set up just that it will james gunn said
the story of those episodes gets way more science
fictiony than you're expecting which really makes
me curious about what it's actually going to be
setting up it should be pretty cool but like i
said his next big movie is going to be guardians
of the galaxy 3 in the marvel universe and that'll
basically tie in with the events of thor love and
thunder there's also a guardians of the galaxy
holiday special which is going to be their marvel
version of a star wars holiday special which
will be canon 2 guardians of the galaxy 3.
big reminder too this week is the start of marvel
what if episodes my episode 1 video will post on
wednesday what if will be canon to the mcu and
it builds on the multiverse craziness from the
loki finale so make sure you have alerts
enabled for my channel so you don't miss
any of those episodes everyone click here for
my full suicide squad post credit scene video
and click here for my full suicide squad breakdown
for the entire movie easter eggs and everything
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next video!